please know if you are going to date a single father
many women have walked that path before you
and when they try to warn you
don't be defensive
do you know what I mean
someone had children with this man and still was like
I can't do it
I don't wanna fucking be with you no more and like
broke it off so not everybody's chasing after that man
no matter what story he's telling you
and I'm not saying this like
with an attitude
I'm saying it like
come on girl
come on let's wake up a little bit
I know I know you know that
I know you hear it in your gut
you know and especially
if he starts to hint and question and ask for you to pay for his legal fees like
oh it's just so
and she's so
you know like just
understand that financial abuse is a very
very real thing
you know and how many women do you know are gold diggers
but how many girls do you know that have gotten played like that you know